je sur les toits du château de saint
chamas tout sincèrement qu'ils étaient
construits par françois 1er c'est ici
par exemple qu'est né louis xiv effet
retrouvé hilaire multon qui est le
directeur du musée d'archéologie
nationale et du domaine de saint germain
en laye hilaire multon jour bonjour
patrice vous êtes le directeur du musée
d'archéologie nationale et du domaine de
saint germain alors un beau quand même
sur ce château
construit bas-fonds se reproduire
exactement on est dans la cour du musée
il existait un château dès le moyen âge
pourquoi les rois venaient à saint
germain pour profiter de la chasse et de
la forêt élégamment et dès cette période
là sous louis 6 au début du deuxième
siècle il ya une attestation d'un
château à saint germain ensuite saint
louis fait construire cette chapelle
chapelle gothique rayonnant tout à fait
impressionnante dans ses dimensions qui
est une des chapelles palatine d'île de
france au même titre que la sainte
chapelle ou que la chapelle de vincennes
qui a accueilli les reliques de la
sainte croix au retour de croisade
lorsque ça lui rentre de croisade et
puis françois 1er qui a l'amour de
l'italie l'amour de l'architecturé
italienne à la fin de son règne convient
à pierre chambly jeu la construction
d'un étrange pentagone on le voit
irrégulier irréguliers ce patagonie
régulier avec des toits en terrasse à la
mode italienne on voit d'ailleurs qu'on
a le f de françois 1er en monogramme
ainsi que la salamandre que l'on trouve
dans tout le val de loire on pense à
blois on pense à chambord symbole donc
de ce roi qui s'est mariée ici dans ce
cadre elle avec claude de france c'est
vraiment parce que c'est vrai qu'on lui
connaît moins de versailles mais il est
beaucoup sur louis xiv est ici bien sûr
louis xiv est pas ici ma main a ici même
pas au château vieux puisque henry 2 on
est tous les valois peu après françois
premier décide de confier à châteauneuf
on est un peu à l'étroit et jusqu'à la
scène il de confier à philibert delorme
un grand chantier que henri iv va
accomplir à la fin du xvième siècle
c'est une beigne riz à l'origine un lieu
moins austère moins formelle comme un
corps étrange pentagone et et c'est vrai
que les rois de france viennent à saint
germain ils sont au louvre bien sûr mais
ils vont à fontainebleau pour chasser
ils viennent à saint germain pour
chasser et la première partie du règne
de louis xiv et de son père louis xiii
qui vit à saint germain c'est la saison
c'est ici que
louis xiv c'est ici juste 792 date à
laquelle le roi soleil décide de partir
mais la sphère des poisons elle se
déroule ici avec toutes les intrigues
qui vont avec les aventures de louis xiv
avec madame de laval hier qu'il repousse
un peu loin au bout au château du val
mais qui n'est jamais bien loin de lui
ses fils est ici madame de montespan
c'était un jardin et donc tout le début
du reg et même la préparation des
guerres on a contraint découvrir en or
de la forêt de saint germain camp
d'entraînement des troubles 2014 le
pouvoir est à saint germain alors il ya
un personnage important que vous
connaissez bien parce que vous y avez
consacré notre thèse cdaf orléans troyes
grâce à qui ce ce château va devenir un
musée d'archéologie exactement puisque
en 1855 la reine victoria est en visite
d'état en france elle se rend sur les
traces de ses ancêtres l'estuaire
puisqu'au départ de louis xiv à
versailles une à quelques temps le
château qui est vide et puis jacques
stuart roi catholique jacques omid
cousin louis xiv est accueilli à saint
germain pendant 24 heures jusqu'à 17 en
exil en exil un contre un par les oranje
nassau qui ont pris le pouvoir en
angleterre et de ce fait il ya une
tradition britannique très forte dans la
ville de saint germain anglo saxon et
louis xiv accueille son cousin et
victoria vient sur les traces de ses
ancêtres découvre un château en ruine
peu digne et de l'idée mais c'est bien
entretenu c'est très mal entretenues
d'ailleurs on aura l'occasion de le
montrer dans les mois qui viennent avec
une belle exposition photographique
consacrée à ce sujet dans cette cour est
bien en 1862 napoléon iii fouilles
d'archéologie décide de créer un musée
des antiquités nationales les antiquités
grecques étrusques et romaines elles
sont au louvre mais l'idée de l'empereur
était de voir tout ce passé c'est
culture matérielle qui gisait dans le
territoire de la gaule depuis les
origines de l'humanité jusqu'à l'époque
romaine et c'est à saint germain c'est
ainsi qu'il installe avec alexandre
bertrand comme premier directeur et tout
un comité ce musée qui est inauguré en
1867 non nous avons fêté les cent
cinquante à cent cinquante ans donc
cette tradition se poursuit vers de
garder des donc ces trésors dans notre
projet national d'archéologie avec quand
même voilà il ya eu des rénovations il
ya des salles qui ont disparu il ya bien
sûr bien sûr une histoire c'est une
histoire des musées en réalité ce musée
une création avec une fort pédagogie des
outils
des moulages des reconstitutions d'armes
de guerre grandeur réelle des balistes
de la guerre des gaules à grandeur
réelle et puis surtout des changements
puisque malraux passionné d'archéologie
vient à saint germain et va rénover le
musée plein de sales il en fait qu'un
une quinzaine du xviii et xixe et puis
dernièrement mars 2012 les nouvelles
salles gauloise inauguré il y a peu qui
ont vraiment rencontré leur public et
leur succès les gaulois sont revenus à
saint germain et c'est vrai on
l'attendait depuis dix ans avec les
fouilles découverte dans les dernières
années une fois que l'archéologie
préventive à accompagner on sait
aujourd'hui en france on a un système
très intéressant lorsqu'il ya un
aménagement un aéroport une route ya de
l'archéologie est ce que on pourrait
regarder peut-être la galerie des
gaulois bien sûr qu'un kaloum à voir et
vous montrer quelques pièces remarquées
avec deux pièces
hilaire multon alors on se trouve dans
la galerie de gaulle où on va faire un
passage très rapide c'est juste pour
donner comme ça quelques idées pour que
les gens viennent
alors là où on est dans la salle ty le
char de roissy dans s'appelle comme ça
parce qu'on a retrouvé la veille à
l'aéroport de roissy exactement et alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que donc
ces salles qui ont été inaugurés en mars
2012 ont l'idée de retrouver ce qui
était la muséographie originel retrouve
cette couleur pourpre henri millet et
puis la redécouverte des plafonds on ne
fait plus d'amuser une boîte noire dans
un château mais on re découvre ses
dimensions dialogue entre l'
architecture et les collections exposées
et donc ses collections d'art sel sont
tout à fait impressionnant et on a ici
reconstituer un une dans les deux tombes
à char qui ont été découverts du moment
où il ya une expansion un accroissement
de l'aéroport de roissy grâce à
l'archéologie préventive de tombes à
char de personnages de haut rang
guerrier avec dans les coffrages à
l'intérieur toutes les pièces qui montre
la parra et l'importance de ces chars
qui étaient surtout des chats de
cérémonie un vainqueur ils sont enterrés
avec donc ils sont enterrés avec pour
signifier leur rang les aimants leur
rend leur appartenance à l'élite à
l'aristocratie et donc c'est tout à fait
intéressant et donc dans cet hommage un
on en dialogue vraiment à ce qui a été
l'origine du musée puisque dans les
années 1860 70 il ya énormément de
tombes à char d'art celles qui sont les
commerces notamment dans le nord-est de
la france ici grâce à l'archéologie
préventive on trouve évidemment et on
complète ses collections on a
reconstitué les deux roues du char
landes avec évidemment tout à fait
considérable mais il ne faut pas
considérer que ce sont des chars
d'assaut d'attac
d'apparat avec les clavette qui vont
avec dans un bronze et un cuivre mêlée
qui fait la spécificité de cet artisanat
sel il faut vraiment rendre hommage à
laure olivier conservateur en chef et
responsable des collections d âge du fer
qui était le maître loeb scientifique
avec joël brière de ce travail de
redécouverte véritablement dollar
gaulois on n'a pas souvent l'onho nos
ancêtres les gaulois avec un mass
marines on est qu une finesse un
raffinement il ya un art qui se dégage
dans la culture celtique avec des formes
zoomorphes d'animaux contre c'est matt
reidy à distinguer la grenouille
l'époque ans qui montre également une
conception symbolique extrêmement élevé
on a même et des éléments qui font
penser à la référence à pythagore et à
la divination au fait de se projeter
dans le futur chez les gaulois dans un
certain nombre de ces tombé à roissy au
pense qu'il s'agit peut-être de la tombe
d'un druide de celui qui avait une
ceinture symbolise les religieux dans la
société gauloise de l'époque donc on
découvre vraiment un art et une
civilisation un art une civilisation et
c'était dès les origines du musée tout à
fait important n'oublions pas que
napoléon iii financent sur ses fonds
personnels les fouilles aller c'est à
levi âme qui est le cas on va le voir
bien bien dessin politiquement voir les
serveurs de voir absolument le plan
d'adhésion absolument il est revenu le
town donc nous sommes devant les
vitrines qui raconte la fameuse batterie
de la leaf oui la fameuse bataille
d'alésia alise sainte reine dans la
côte-d'or actuelle sur ça sans contester
c'est qu'on est aimé les preuves
archéologiques qui sont donnés ici en
plus de la source littéraire la guerre
des gaules de ces arbres jeu là on a
tous les éléments qui ont été découverts
par les archéologues au 19e siècle au
moment où il ya les fous du napoléon iii
des années 1860 et puis par des fouilles
récentes d'une équipe franco allemande
et notamment avec michel rey des côtés
français donc on a ici du matériel de
guerre on le voit les clous des
légionnaires romains et ont beau des
boucliers les flèches les grilles on n'a
rien inventé finalement pour faire en
sorte que les comment ce passe dans de
meilleurs délais et puis un peu plus
loin évidemment tout un tas d'éléments
qui montre l'esprit dans lequel cette
bataille c'est organiser les catapultes
donc en fait l'analyse est un lieu ou
sur le plan archéologique on a des
traces d'une bataille tout à fait
massive important donc savait que
vercingétorix coordonne les armées de la
gaule c'est un chef arverne et c'est un
siège qui va durer et on a là les
attestations aux miroirs par
l'archéologie et les traces matérielles
de la bataille de ce que nous décrit
césar dans la guerre des gaules c'est à
dire la prise dans land difficile delà
du siège et de l'oppidum d'alésia c'est
ça c'est forbidden parmi les nombreuses
preuves archéologiques du fait que
alésia et bien à un désir si j'ose dire
à alise-sainte-reine on a d'abord les
fameux fausser les doubles faussé
puisque les armées de césar les armées
romaines étaient enserrés va de pousser
pour éviter une descente de l'assaillant
et des soutiens extérieurs la
contrebande à sion et la circonvolution
les deux fossés on les a retrouvés dans
le domaine archéologique et césar en
palmes la guerre des gaules et puis
autre preuves archéologiques
c'est la numismatique la monnaie les
monnaies que l'on trouve et notamment
ceux cester en or qui fait référence qui
a eu d'inscription en référence au chef
arverne en l'occurrence vercingétorix
qui à coaliser les ennemis de césar dans
la gaule de l'époque donc on a là une
preuve archéologiques au delà des
monnaies clooney couvert dans d'autres
disciplines et du fait de son caractère
précieux de l'importance de ce siège de
son caractère stratégique et de la
présence des armées gauloise coalisés
contre la présence romaine dans cette
gaulle qui va dessiner un nouveau
paysage en réalité en occident avec la
naissance du monde gallo romains avec
des emprunts est assez étonnant alors
ben voilà il suffit de venir ici à saint
germain dans ce musée poe pour voir tout
ça